let's talk about the mob so so uh
the when we started talking and uh you
know michael francis and you you had
been on this show before i think it was
something that i've been done before and
i called you we started talking together
and told you about the project what
turned you on to want to participate in
mafia states of america
what i really felt was when when you
when i heard about it i said wow i
thought about i said has there ever been
a two maid guy two really bosses
sit down and have a sit down
where people could see it
and i thought about i said no never
i said this would be really interesting
and then i saw sammy's podcast and i saw
michael's and obviously yours and i said
wow i said this could be really
something if
if this could really work you know if
it's real
if it's real if it's honest
that's then i said i would want to if
it's going to be like you know you're
going to have enactments of things ah
i don't want that i want to be involved
in that but if it's really real and raw
which mafia states is
when michael and sami sit down with
patrick
i said okay i like to be involved in
that you know and then i met jerrod
obviously the director and uh i said
okay you know this could be good
you know i i go by my gun if something
looks and feels right
hey you know take a chance let's see
what happens yeah and you even you wrote
a lot for this as well you you
contribute on the writing side yeah i i
like to because i like to if i'm going
to be in it i i always ask would you
mind if i write and draw it was very
gracious
you know but but that that's what a good
director does they you know they if they
see something in someone there as a
director you galvanize people you
encourage people to make the project
better so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]